welcome everyone thank you for having me
my name is Rob relax listen I'm gonna
talk today about command line by show
hands those of you honestly who don't
know what the command line is just show
your hand cool - nice - and a half ha ha
that was a joke ok cool so this is meant
to be it looks exhaustive on the list
and I'm not sure how long will take let
me check the time okay but I don't think
it'll be as exhaustive as it looks like
I will cover some things that I used on
a daily basis and we'll go in to short
detail of what to command on this and
maybe why you should use it
I'll give you actually a little bit of
info at the end about how I made these
slides because that's an interesting
story they look a bit different from the
slides I've had recently so I'll get to
that but yeah my name is Rob Jackson you
can find me on all on most things as at
Rob Axelson coincidentally I also have
everywhere on all the things so I'm at
on all the things at on all the things
but those are mainly elias's for now
Rob axelsson is where I actually am I'm
a self-taught developer like we talked
about earlier I'm a speaker a meetup
organizer I'm a community enthusiast and
then there's a long sentence there but
all I want to say is that I love it when
just like today one code and people come
together and I love to get to know
people help people learn to code and be
in be amongst other geeks and code
enthusiasts awesome
so as I said earlier this is talk is by
no means meant to be exhaustive and I
hope that if you could realize something
at part of the talk you're like oh but
he should mention this or that's wrong
or whatever
feel free to mention to me afterwards or
even better commits a pull request
because the talks are already on the
talk slides are already
online and this is meant to be mainly
for beginners people that haven't really
opened a terminal or the command line
before or if you're a little bit
familiar but you know you like not sure
why you should use the command line more
or you a bit too scared or you're like
okay now's the time to maybe get better
at this I'm gonna try and give you a
jump start yeah one thing that I think
we should make clear first is in terms
of the command line the command line is
just the opposite or an alternative to
the GUI the graphical interface that you
used to use to do stuff on your computer
you might go to YouTube to watch videos
you can also download YouTube videos
from the command line with commands for
example you might like to use graphical
tools when you are committing your
source code meaning you're creating some
code or you're programming something and
you have a visual tool that helps you
keep track of all of that you can do
that from the command line you can play
games from the command line you can do
all sorts of things but for me it's
mainly a way of being more productive
and as it becomes muscle memory it also
feels like it looks to others like I'm
having magical powers and it kind of
feels like that sometimes as well
because if you make the effort and it
becomes part of your routine there is an
initial steep learning curve for sure
depending on what you're using the
command line for but if you're willing
to give it that give that an effort you
will benefit from it and also some of
this is stuff that you will eventually
have to know as a developer normally if
you are using an IDE or you're in a
company where you have like IntelliJ or
some IDE which does almost everything
and you just have some terminal inside
the IDE okay maybe you won't really have
to know so much but at some point it
will only benefit any developer or
programmer to know some stuff about the
command line and some of the stuff we're
sharing today will just be basic stuff
that will help you but if you don't know
it from before
c'mon like give me many things there is
a command line in Windows I won't go
into that unless you install what's it
called bash for Windows or something
like this where you get basically Linux
interface in Windows you will sorry
sequin ok Coco and you also benefit from
this talk with some disk land of
disclaimers with some exceptions most of
this stuff will work on Mac as well
because Mac is also UNIX based bsd based
I just included some stuff mainly from
Wikipedia here in terms of what UNIX is
but it is in essence an operating system
that there are current operating systems
that are derived from it's a
simplification but as all you need to
know and one thing to mention which we
won't go into depth on today but which
you might notice later on is that UNIX
has a philosophy of having modules for
everything and every program or tools
should be really good at what it does
and then it can be chained or combined
with other commands or tools and they
together will do the job really
brilliantly for you I won't go into any
advanced examples but if you're
interested in that kind of way of yeah
controlling your computer from the color
online and benefiting from that kind of
philosophy that's a whole different talk
topic but it's just nice to know not so
much about bash other than that we will
at the end I'll go through some a little
bit of demo
feel free to save questions to the end
because of the talk is not so easy to
with the recording it's not so easy to
have a questions live so please we'll
keep them in mind bash is a shell and
command language meaning the command
line that you get up on Linux or Mac
will be bash based and the commands you
give outside of using a tool or a
certain command with some options those
will be bash commands
it's called born again shell and it's
some yeah enough said there's a great
resource if you want to go into how to
customize your bash and make your
command like line look different or
program and bash whatever there's a
great github resource which called
awesome bash where there's tons of
resources these commands that I've
listed here control our control a
control a control L and clear those are
the ones that will make you the most
productive in terms of using bash those
are eccentric meaning control are takes
up all the previous it has the history
your bash history all the commands you
previously have done in the command line
I think by default of the thousand last
commands then you can basically search
in them as you start control art and
start typing out it'll give you the last
command and then a history of the
previous commands you've done that
started with the same thing control a
makes you jump to the front of the line
you're on and control e to the end
feel free to code along or do this but
the slides are also online so you don't
have to write down something control L
is the same as clear it clears the
screen you can also write clear just
write clear enter and it does the same
job before we start just know that a
good habit to get from the start is the
man pages meaning most every for example
Linux tool command-line tool will have a
manual page man page and you can
normally just do man and space and the
programmer tool that you are wanting to
get more information on so we talked
about bash you can even do man bash and
you'll get tons of information starts
with a title description example or the
syntax and it gives you the options and
maybe some examples for those options
options will get a little bit into later
but that's not really stuff you have to
get so familiar with just to get
familiar with the command line get as we
talked about earlier with github that's
a version control system and the most
popular one to date by far
this is where you keep track of all the
versions of the programs you're right if
you code something you might do
something today you put you commit it
meaning you save it you save it locally
but you can also choose to save it for
example at github or a private
repositories is only available for you
but you know that if your computer
crashes it's still there you can pull it
down this also makes it easier to
contribute to collaborate with other
people so that you can push your code
they can take that code down to make
changes and simplify it but that's part
of what this tool does and all this you
can do from the command line sometimes
you start with get in it there's a lot
of code here we'll go through those
commands here we'll go through of those
some other things together later but and
I know a lot of this is just throwing
stuff at you and it might be Wow but I
my goal partly is if you remember 10% of
these things and then you're in a
situation we're like oh I think I can do
that's hopefully helpful getting it
you're starting a new project often if
you're starting to learn the code you do
git clone instead because you're putting
down someone else's code then you
normally get familiar with git status
and git add git status shows you really
good overview and often gives you
suggestions about exactly what you
should do in that case git add lets you
add new files or change the files that
have been changed you add them to the
stage the environment but let's not get
into get specifics and get commits that
command means that you are storing the
new version of your source code with a
message that it should be descriptive of
what it does and git push is when you're
pushing it to locally or normally a
remote place where the code lives but
these are the codes that you like 80% of
your normal working day would get unless
you have like a advanced workflow in
your company or with your you know open
source project that gets you very far
maybe to give some context if I do this
I have a terminal window here that I use
that is a drop-down we can show you how
to open one normally on Linux afterwards
when I talk about the command line this
is what I'm talking about
just to give some visuals if it was
unclear then we can create files and
directories from the command line the
easiest way is the touch command again
if you're curious to give some more
context I can command touch and it gives
me information about what this command
does for me right so it changes the file
timestamps but we can use it to create
files it has options as you see here in
s the description and it has the options
and it gives us information about what
they do and it says you need to touch
and you can do an option that's optional
but you need a file name yeah so if we
touch a file it's a file doesn't exist
before it creates the file it's an empty
file there's like no bits it's like it's
just an empty file and that's helpful
sometimes but sometimes you want to
create a file because you already know
what you want to put in it so from the
command line you can use bash syntax of
echoing out and then in strings whatever
is going to be there and then you direct
it to that file that file will then have
that content there are text editing
tools in your command line the simplest
one probably being nonno because it you
can follow instructions and stuff we'll
get to another one later so you can also
just yunano file tree and then you're
opening your file and then you get
instructions on how to save it after you
put some information into the file it's
not so important to note differences but
I mentioned that this one over writes
everything in the file and this one lets
you always a pen so if there is
something already existing in file -
this means that this will be added to it
then I won't go into detail today but
it's more powerful editor than Nano some
people myself included use it to program
all day long so it can be a fully
functional and more than enough
productive IDE for you if you want a
program to make a directory you use make
death m'kay dr dir and one thing you'll
use more often if at anything more than
that is the p up flag the p option which
just lets you make more than one
directory at once because if you try
without the flag it'll say that
directory you want to create a directory
inside it doesn't exist yeah and now
that we've created and directories and
files we maybe want to have a look at
them so LS gives us a simple overview or
where we are and what files are
available and as again with options so
you see here is an example of some tools
lets you have options or flags like la a
la h together some of them enforce you
to have a dash in front of all of them
there is a bit of inconsistency between
commands and tools unfortunately so it's
good again to check the main pages if
there's one thing you remember today
from this talk if you get confused to
the command line there's something
you're supposed to use just to man
before the command and see what happens
you can get a lot on just by looking in
the local information you have available
for you
lah is an example of list them not just
in a row but as a list list the files as
a list has lists all the file in your
current directory a thank you list all a
for all and H is human readable so if
you get sizes in bits and you like how
many megabits or whatever is that then
you can use that option CD dot dot when
you are already no sorry we go into this
directory so we have a directory my dear
hello we can do either CD my dear then
again CD hello or we can do the forward
slash because it's my hello is a
directory in my dear and once we're in
there we use the dot dot to go one
directory back
and we can do a slash dot to go to
directories back or to levels and then
we can do that infinite like as many
times this we have like there are some
file system limitations I think but I
don't think you'll run into them I think
it's more long filenames
find it's the simplest command or that
is always there to find a file so
forward slash will find everything in
your computer and the name denotes what
you're looking for us the name and the
dot is from your current directory and
downwards or up yeah downwards upwards
whatever I don't know at least inside
that directory in all the directories
inside that directory and one thing I
maybe should put a resource here but if
you want to install a tool that makes
your life easier in terms of find just
install ACK or and help me remember this
you can also do FCF which is a fuzzy
finder which you can replace the control
R with this and it was even more
powerful in terms of finding not just
your history but there's also other
combinations of stuff we can find based
on file name to confuse you less fuzzy
finder just means you don't even have to
type out the full name you can like if
something is cat fake I can write CT PC
and because that filename contains those
I can do quicker like a fuzzy search
manipulating files I will get to some
examples afterwards it's getting really
tough now but bear with me getting back
to the touch command if you do the
option D you can you can specify
actually now we don't want to create a
file we want to take an existing file
and we want to give it a new timestamp
meaning we created it four weeks ago but
for some odd reason we want to make it
appear that we created it two days two
hours ago so then you can just specify a
file and you can do touch with the flag
D for a date stamp I think and then you
can even specify in like tier tags two
hours ago and you can also do date
formats and then the file you want to
change and then in like both
next sir if you copy to Windows it'll
appear as if it was created or no as if
that was it last time it was edited
modified RM removes the file RM don't
play too much with RM if you don't know
what to do you can do stuff like RM RF
which removes enforces and doesn't don't
ask you for confirmation then you can do
the forward slash like we used looked at
earlier the whole computer and then you
have a you're gonna have a good time but
our Aman is own specifying one specific
file unless use an Asterix should be
fine manipulating files we had that in
the previous slide but you can then with
this redirect you can only append so
you're updating this file to have a new
line with more content again now I know
it's useful if you want to change files
you can change the file name with just
MD which is its own again you know UNIX
philosophy MV does one job really good
it's good at moving files changing names
doing that stuff really good that's what
it does it's always there for you man
and V you get all the options so you
move it and then you can change the name
so the existing name and the new name
you can copy a file so this would move
it file to would be gone and file new
name would be there copy would then copy
this one and copied into file tree and
both of them then exist and a nice trick
if you want to if you do backups and you
often like oh yeah I just want to backup
this file and change it like config
files or whatever you can do copy file
too and then you do some don't quote me
on this but I think this might be perl
magics it might not be fully bash but
you do the curly brackets comma dot
backup means that it it could take some
parameters before the comma but now we
don't give it anything so we're just
saying take the file name that you have
and create a new file with that same
file name plus dot backup dot B KP for
example so if you use that and you get
it in your fingers you have a quicker
way of copying a file if you always want
to do like dot bak or B KP or whatever
for backing up that file so you know if
you make changes and
revert you can just yeah them I think I
have to show some stuff here because if
I just do if I'd used them like file one
right this is a text editor
okay how what do I do now like this is
really not the parent like I'm just
clicking random buttons now and suddenly
something happened because I click the
button I which means insert mode if I do
escape I can do :
and I can do commands here I can do help
so it's not the most intuitive editor
but it's really feature-rich the best
way to get familiar with it is just to
go help them tutor and then you get a
file which leads to true like do this
this way and try this out stuff and do
it on this file and you you know you
learn as you go along but I don't want
to spend too much time on this but that
may be one thing to just remember really
good is that I don't manage so there you
go it's that if you want to escape this
let me just blow this up you literally
just have to remember cue and you might
have to remember and exclamation mark
because if you don't
uh-huh because sorry because if you
don't then I'll tell you you did change
oh yeah it will work if it was empty so
it will work now who but if I did it
change it won't work because there was a
you'd changed something in the file
since you last wrote to it so then the
safest way is to always know that it's :
q enter and then you're safe because
then you can exit them you learn today
how to exit them and use that vent a
with man pages I think that's more than
enough as a takeaway and the escape key
is your friend I've gone so far as I've
switched permanently my escape and caps
lock key because caps lock is quick it's
closer to my finger
it's pardon the French sucks when I use
someone else's computer but it works or
someone else uses my computer will
actually do some of this example in the
end I have to get up the IP address
because I have a server ready for us I
just want to mention that for some of
you when you get into the backend or if
you do some coding you want to put your
code somewhere you might have to deal
with another server but the command line
is just the server is mainly just you
interfacing with another computer and
you do it most often like 98% of the
time via the command line unless you're
on Windows for example and the stuff
that you do on the server is often a lot
of the stuff you would do on your normal
computer if you use the command line so
this is an example of going SSH meaning
we're connecting a tunnel through a
server secure connection where we can
then use the command line locally but
through the SSH tunnel on the other
computer team Oakes is a great tool that
enables us to if we just do some stuff
in the server and then we close the
connection we go back again the last
session we had is gone t marks are a
great tool like new screen lets us open
a session that we can close and then we
close this connection we go back to the
server we can continue where we left off
you can also use T MUX locally because
it lets you split the screen in new
terminal different session sections and
it can be a good workflow a tool but
it's nice to know that you can do that
and then vim again you could for example
have a workflow where you connect to a
server you do T MUX to set up a session
you do them to code some stuff you leave
it there you go away you can connect
back in two days and hopefully the
session is still there unless someone
screwed with a server or it went down or
whatever and control B D just lets you
when you're in T MUX detach from that
session then you do t MUX attached
unless you have already more sessions
and then you can do T MUX LS which is
allows for lists and you can see if you
have more sessions and then you can
selectively choose which team are
session to go back into
this is more advanced but now you know
that that's stuff you can do I guess
process management and now we're on 14
of 17 sites it's not so much left
awesome there's a great tool that is not
so often known about I think that's
called pit off so let me take a step
back in your Mac or your Linux
there's processes running I don't know
so much about the windows world there
but there are processes but they're
managed different this far as I know so
here you would want to for example close
down your Firefox that broke or Google
Chrome or your video player like oh stop
froze what happened then you can go and
have a look at for the for you to
instruct the computer on what to do you
normally need the process ID app it is
just the process ID of something a
program like Google Chrome web for
example you can just repeat a program
instead of having to do PS Ochs and more
advanced tools to find and then grab
foreign stuff like if you just want to
do simple stuff paid off does a great
job it just finds you the paid off a
program then you get a pit like an ID a
number then you can kill that number
that ID that paid that program and then
normally it just closes down and maybe
your computer unfreezes this is
simplified because you would go more
into depth into this administration
system administration stuff like keep
track of stuff and have an idea what
have been sleeping and whole thing and
like what is hogging the most memory and
the processor is power whatever it's
called
top is a nice tool that's always there
but if you do use Linux or I think it's
available with homebrew you can use h
top which is a even more simple
graphical user interface for managing
this a little bit more with like f3 and
f10 and searching and make cities
simpler for you but it's still in the
command line
maybe yes I'll show you this first after
or actually the last thing will demo
remember remind me to tell you about
nyan cat it's a great surprise to finish
the talk you don't have to just be
serious and all
yeah she said me with the command-line
there are great resources and I
mentioned these guys before hack five
hak5 they've been around forever they
have tons of great videos not just this
playlist but tons about if you want to
get more familiar with the command-line
they're great at explaining stuff to
keep it simple maybe just a couple of
commands per video it's really nice this
talk was made in vim so you saw before
the talk maybe we had some like last
minute like whoa some stuff I [ __ ] up
some pardon my french I managed to mess
up with some stuff so this talk is
created in the command-line the first
time I do this because I wanted
something where I can just do that it's
an indirect index.html file that I'm
just modifying in them and it's been
March AS which is a library for doing
slides in your browser and you just
create you just write markup so you see
it's an HTML file with some stuff on top
it imports some fonts then at the bottom
it will then take the script needed for
the JavaScript so the slideshow script
is this remark yes but in between here
all I'm writing is the content of the
stuff that you saw now the whole talk is
here starting with the talk contents and
it's written in markdown my plan is to
get a little bit more experience with
this and maybe add my own style but I
really liked it this time around the
slides are available in our repo for a
perceived free call cam Vienna and we
mark yes you can check out so I think
we'll start by just having a short
demonstration we've gone a bit longer
than I thought
so we'll keep it short but we'll go to
the server that I put up for us
we'll connect to the server and we can
play around with some commands and then
we'll try nyan cat in the end and after
the talk feel free to ask questions well
I still have the stuff up we can show
something quickly if there's something
related so now I'm just don't let that
confuse you but let me SSH
like we had a command example into a
server is it big enough should I
is that good so now I'm connecting to a
server in a data center in front fault
so this is not my computer anymore and
here we saw the example of you for
example using tea mugs so I can use the
clear command I can use right stuff
control L let's bash stuff I can write
stuff here and jump to the front jump to
the end I can write some silly commands
and then next time I drew controller but
that might not work this time around oh
it does it sure shows us that the last
time we started with Dee we wrote the SF
so I can do the same one again team-ups
I won't show you that here then because
I remember now I was in the process of
reinstalling it's when my kid was hungry
so I didn't install it on the server it
will take a while because we have to
update the whole process the whole cache
here but I'll show you Tmax afterwards
and we could use vim here to just I
think we'll take a step back and don't
do that because we will use it locally
we did do the server stuff we connect it
to the server I'll show you tea mugs
yeah let's just go locally for the sake
of example let's pretend I'm on the
server now I can do T MUX you see
there's even a command there's even like
a graphical thing down here with some
information this might be some
modifications here in my conflicts but
now I can do control like I can do some
stuff here right I can do like I can
even open a vem session and then I can
do you see there stuff here right this
is a list of the files there now I can
control BD I'm out again and I can do
stuff you know I can even close this
window and stuff
and then I go back if I don't do
anything else and go back it goes back
to the it doesn't go back to the same
place so tea mugs so tells me there's a
window open and then I can doubt goatee
marks attached t0 and now we're back to
where we were so this stuff is still
running in the background normally if a
closed terminal is gone and UNIX world
we can see for example peed off and we
shouldn't do it on Google Chrome because
it has it's a bad example it has a lot
of crumbs here a lot of tabs and stuff I
think it's maybe stable just Google
doesn't work just a bit of tilde ok this
terminal that you see now is called
tilde I knew it was there it gives us a
this one let me just check if there's
some stuff I don't want to close here
it's fine so if I now do kill this one
the chair was gone whoa it actually did
it did but we told it to do and because
I killed it I have to take it up again
so ok that was one example just to show
you a different one that you can this is
still the command line this does the job
of telling us all the programs that are
running here I can even search for
Google gives us the one on top here and
I can kill Google Chrome now and this is
easier because you see the the shortcuts
down there and this is easier to
navigate around especially if you're new
to the command line
I think we'll just create a file and
then we'll do the nine cat and we'll
finish so I am here now I'm listing out
all the files here and listing it in a
better format using flags so we can see
the size and your human readable way and
so forth then I want to go and make a
directory I do my dear
hello but it tells me you can equate it
because my dear doesn't exist so we use
the flag we talked about earlier now
there exists my dear hello it's just too
small maybe now we're here now I can
touch a fight so there's nothing here
now I can touch a file now there is a
file living here I can touch file two
and three and four now there are more
files here I can list them like this and
then I can do echo this is awesome and I
can put that into file one there's
another command let's just print out
everything in the file to the screen so
we see this house now this is awesome
then I want to have another file another
line in that file and it shows us this
file contains these two things and we
can figure that out again with vim so it
shows us now we can edit this stuff and
I can add a third line awesome it's
there so I'm using the command I'm just
using the stuff you saw earlier it might
seem like magic when I'm doing it and
I'm even using ctrl a to go back here
tell-tell using them and I'm doing that
right it's not that complicated just
needs to practice practice practice and
it's in your fingers I think we're good
to end now on a good note if you don't
have nine cat won't always be there you
have to install it you have to install
this program um sure it's on homebrew on
Mac it's on Linux and you get a nice
nyan cat in your command line it has
colors and stuff it's awesome this is
something you can do
if you do like a full screen like this
you open up a terminal you put it
fullscreen
you put a nyan cat on your colleagues or
friends computer don't tell me I did it
and I'm not endorsing this in any way
this is not plural ah and you can just
leave the screen there like what you can
also go to nyan cat calm no nyan cat and
gives you an ice cream so I think that's
it thanks for your well thanks for your
attention and yeah
[Applause]